welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the thor live and thunder
trailer revealed jane foster is the
mighty thor but framed thor's jacked axe
with an even deeper mystery a reforged
mjolnir and based on those cracks it's
not a fresh mjolnir from a past timeline
or from another reality but it is the
broken mjolnir from this reality after
hella shattered it and thor ragnarok
it's uru pieces reassembled by some
unknown process called gorilla glue good
night everyone don't forget to buy our
shark bye bye
don't know mjolnir's return has been my
biggest question about love and thunder
ever since psycho with tt introduced
natalie portman holding that hammer
despite its status and mcu present as uh
wrecked and cap returning that alternate
timeline won in endgame and in the jason
aaron comics since jane foster's story
is based on mjolnir does not begin that
series broken it's just dropped in the
dirt by thor after his experience with
gore mjolnir is broken other times in
the comics but not here so this presents
two mysteries one obviously jane
foster's power up into lady thor which
is its own fascinating question for
another day because before we can even
get to that how has mjolnir been fixed
at first i thought the answer might be
the same as the reason behind jane's
condition but now i think these
explanations are actually different one
leading to the other so to understand
how mjooner could ever be fixed we have
to re-examine how it was destroyed how
was hella able to break mjolnir in
ragnarok our inference from that film
was that based on the hidden ceiling art
and asgard revealing hella as the
original bearer of mjolnir before thor
was even born that hella had some power
over the hammer that predated thor and
predated odin's worthiness charm plus
hella is hella strong and her
destruction of mjolnir was meant to be a
demonstration of her power now mjolnir
like all the most powerful weapons in
the mcu was forged by the dwarves of
ninja velir out of the metal uru
stormbreaker's blade is made of uru as
is the infinity gauntlet and thanos's
double-bladed sword according to the
director's infinity war and end game but
even if the armorers of nina velir
crafted mjolnir specifically for hela
and she was its original wielder that
has never really been a satisfactory
enough reason for me at least that she
should be uniquely able to destroy it as
well like by that logic would
stormbreaker be able to be destroyed if
it was squeezed hard enough by thor or
for that matter by groot since groot
supplied a critical part of that weapon
good thanos just thanos without his
infinity stones pry apart the infinity
gauntlet like i don't even know if he
had all the stones if he'd be able to
destroy the gauntlet too because they
contain the blast of all those stones
together and when he used that blast to
hit another weapon out of uru
stormbreaker cut right through it i mean
we're talking about god killing weapons
here folks heated with the power of a
star infused with some kind of
enchantment they should at least be
resistant to an overtight grip of an
asgardian as guardians known for their
hot tempers
so to destroy something made out of uru
is a really big deal and other than
hella breaking mjolnir there was only
one other time we saw this happen in the
mcu that was when wanda maximov
splintered thanos sword in endgame using
her sorcery wanda is the scarlet witch
hella isn't as guardian witch practicing
the same kind of asgardian witchcraft
that frigga taught loki and i think it
is possible that when hella broke
mjolnir she was harnessing the same dark
magic maybe even chaos magic that wanda
uses now yes i can hear the screams wait
one is chaos magic is red hella
sorcery's green i watched new rockstars
videos you guys have been telling me all
reds are chaos all greens are time all
purples are dramaboo yes while i think
it is fun to try to categorize the mcu
that way that is not how the production
designers across these films build these
movies from the inside out the mcu is
not an eight-color box of crayola
crayons yes back in phase three the
color coding applied to the infinity
stones but now that the infinity stones
are gone not every orange glow stick in
the mcu is someone's soul folks it
really could just be as simple as milner
was broken with witchcraft and with
witchcraft it has been reforged because
this movie's official description says
jane quote inexplicably wields his
magical hammer mjolnir inexplicably
could refer to this asgardian magic
because while frigate taught loki that
kind of sorcery she did not teach it to
thor cause thor didn't need it he was
born the god of thunder to thor odin's
charm and loki's sorcery are a big
mystery to him he attributes all
asgardian magic to asgardian science and
i don't think this guy gets science that
much either like it didn't scribble
smartest on that trucker hat now huge
thanks to extra the world's largest
smart wallet brand for sponsoring this
video extra designs the smartest wallets
in the world which you can track with
their solar-powered tracker worldwide so
if you ever have trouble finding your
wallet your tracker is here to help you
find it instantly it's voice activated
and solar powered two hours of sunshine
gives it a three month charge so really
just download the chippelo app on your
phone and then you can ring your wallet
from your phone or your phone from your
wallet it works with google home alexa
and siri i'm just gonna run a little
test here put my tracker chip in the
wallet having a bit too much fun on a
roller coaster and whoa there it goes
i think is that kearney's gonna help you
you just tap your chipolo app in
oh between the two kids who were puking
and found my wallet now extra slim
profile wallets are awesome they're made
of premium leather they have rfid
protection and you use this little
button on the side to fan out your cards
so no more overstuffed wallets no more
giant lumps in your back pocket check
out the wallets with the link below and
use promo code new rockstars for up to
15 off site wide at shop.exter.com
new rockstars 3 that's code new
rockstars to maximize your savings at
shop.exter.com newrockstars3 now yes of
course jane was infected with the ether
reality stone back in thor the dark
world and in the mcu infinity stones do
emit cosmic radiation that continues to
have an effect on this universe even
after the stones themselves have been
atomized that is how radiation works
like even after you remove the initial
uranium from somewhere the other things
that uranium has irradiated can still
irradiate other things and this is the
explanation marvel producers have given
when asked why this universe didn't
completely unravel when the stones were
atomized it's because their energy
continues to course through this
universe i actually think this radiation
could be the explanation behind jane's
cancer i also suspect it could have been
the explanation behind maria rambo's
cancer in one division but while reality
stone radiation may remain in the
universe one's ability to weaponize the
reality stone to manipulate matter the
way thanos could in infinity war that
practical functionality was lost the
moment the stone was atomized so i'm not
so sure residual reality stone energy is
enough of an explanation for how the
hammer could be reforged now a bit of a
warning here we're about to show you
some set imagery from the love and
thunder set though really this has been
making the rounds for about a year now
you probably have seen it but we do know
that jane foster will encounter the
broken shards of uru in new asgard and
they are sitting upon a mound pedestal
that has been dug out presumably on that
same spot on the grass on the cliff
where hella left them suggesting that no
one could move them and therefore odin's
worthiness charm remained in the pieces
even in their broken state so the word
inexplicably plus the general close to
the vest nature of this initial teaser
giving us mostly vibes and withholding
the villain suggests to me that thor
love and thunder is waiting until after
dr strange is the multiverse of manus
releases before revealing more about
love and thunder's plot why well
multiverse of madness is probably gonna
show the scarlet witch wreaking havoc on
reality the same way we saw her do on a
smaller scale in one division in fact a
recent promo even showed a similar
close-up of her eyes glowing red the
same way they did at the end of episode
six of wanovision the moment she
expanded the west view hex to encompass
and warp the sword perimeter camp and
all the surrounding businesses
multiverse madness is likely to feature
wanda doing the same kind of thing but
across the entire universe of the mcu
and the way things like thanos snap was
a universe-wide shockwave that we have
revisited moment by moment from various
character perspectives i think wanda's
blast of chaos magic will trickle down
to a variety of mcu vignettes from here
forward and transfigure things in those
moments one of which might be jane
foster standing in front of the broken
pieces of mjolnir in the way we have
seen wanda's witchcraft splinter uru
weapons in endgame by that logic the
same process can be used to forge uru
pieces back together in thor love and
thunder perhaps even part of a pattern
of wanda making all things that were
broken whole again vision her family
tears in reality a universe previously
segregated from mutant kind to all of
that fix the broken this would be a
secret understandably withheld from the
first love and thunder teaser but
something that would make a lot more
sense after multiverse of madness
reminder you could support new rockstars
by checking out our merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
the rockstar subscribe to narc stars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you